hi my name is Mary and I'm from Phoenix
and I wanted to know we're seeing a lot
of characters that are not from
storytellers fairy tales what is your
favorite character that you would like
to see from a fictional novel on the
show or just invited chef I got a list
on the show on the show got it oh I'll
start with Oliver Twist
yeah Nexen Richard Nixon it's story no I
don't know about that choice I call
shenanigans okay who's next Coleman I
want to see the Three Little Pigs
maybe Indiana Jones Wow oh boy um I
don't I don't know that one yeah I gosh
I was gonna say parents on solo
I was gonna say service sorry ha ha
I think we should have Dora the explora
what about Annie
tomorrow Darth Vader you say Darth Vader
I did say that Vader that's very telling
I'm telling you something's changed it's
change think you have no idea I don't
you know what no longer okay who's next
hi hi I'm uh my friend wanted meet ask
your friend your friend wanted you guys
I see wanted me to ask how the Evil
Queen coming back is going to impact us
know and really
Regina's relationship well the Evil
Queen if we remember the one thing she
wanted most in the world was Snow
White's heart and that will not stop oh
but I think that one of the things that
I really loved in the course of the five
seasons is watching how Regina turns to
snow and they've really become friends
and I think we're going to see very
early on we're going to see that
relationship further and Regina is for
the very first time going to have a
group of people to support her while her
half is going to be trying to kill
everyone and cause a lot of mischief
yeah you know the Regina Snow
relationship was kind of you know ground
zero for the show
it started with Regina breaking of the
wedding and there's been so much that's
happened between them since then that
you know it's something that we really
do start to explore this season even
more that relationship their past and
their future together I wanted to ask a
question about was your friend okay with
that answer I want to see the face of
the know I wanna see really see the
Frenchman's yeah I have a question about
um the Olympian crystal yeah okay um
wins Elena shove it into Hades he was
completely obliterated my God does know
more when Hades shot Robin his spirit
seemed to float away but the body
remained well you know first of all like
it you know everything that was said
about the interview personal was was
said by 80s Hades
said that stuff about the Olympian
crystal I don't know he was he's god of
the underworld kind of lies
can we trust him can we trust I would
say in all seriousness that's a question
that I think you know some of our
characters should and will ask you know
it's okay I like that answer I should
like that answer a show about hope you
know I would I wouldn't choose not to
believe Hades but we'll find out did you
hear that I'm doing what I can't up here
everybody I'm doing what I can
hi honey what's your question hi I'm
Natalie from Devas inside hi everybody
hi so my question is for Josh um in the
first season when David was
quote-unquote married to Catherine he
was wearing a way was cursed he wore a
wedding ring
but then when the curse was lifted he
never put one up back on why is that cuz
it means it's the same person really
come on she's upset about an excellent
point
Celeste Josh answer it Josh yeah what
are you doing I don't know no right
right now Joshua drops yeah we're in the
ring excellent getting an atom on the
phone I yeah I don't know why I don't
know why he hasn't done the ring I guess
that's a question for Eddie now you know
what let's put the ring on and then we
don't have to worry about the ring on
the ring is coming back thank you how
was your course
- I'm Sienna and I'm from Toronto Canada
and you're adorable and my question is
um when you found out you got the part
what was your reaction for everybody
yeah cuteness guys I guess
I resign again whoever wants to get in
there okay when when when I found out
that I got the part I completely freaked
out I was I love the role from the
moment I saw it so when I found out that
I got it I freaked out I honestly did I
think I was crying okay me too quitting
right now I totally freaked out I was
walking the dog and I had a bag of
something as you do when you walk the
dog and spoiler alert wasn't nice and
walking along my agent Gordon she went
once upon a time we'll need to be on the
show like don't know what the role is
you probably wonder why I'm like nom
alright and so I said yes I didn't even
know what it was one of the best days of
my life
sorry I find me I mean it's all right
it's like our friendship you know ears
hearing whatever I yeah well these guys
called me and and you know said do you
want to be part of the show and I loved
them we got to work together and lost
and so it was just an immediate yes
of course and just you know I love the
show and I love the Casas that was
amazing
very very happy yeah super excited I
freaked out too yeah the phone rang and
it was my agent but I didn't know
because she said hi is Regina there and
I said I'm sorry if wrong number Regina
and I said wrong number Lana you got the
part I opened a bottle of champagne yeah
I can't beat that story I was thrilled I
love the script from the very start
I didn't think then all of us went into
throes of panic because it was working
on How I Met Your Mother at the time and
I had to beg the showrunner was of How I
Met Your Mother
to flip the last two episodes of the
season in order for the schedule to work
so we went into crisis mode and then and
then excitement vote so the champagne
came after the crisis I was really like
no I was absolutely provided because I
cuz I obviously didn't think that anyone
like I didn't think I'll be playing
Captain Hook cuz you know traditionally
sort of yeah quite a bit older so I was
I was through I'm very excited to go
into leather pants how I recall oh my
dear hi ladies
how are you hi I'm Carrie and I'm from
Los Angeles thanks and I'm her mom
Christy by the way that is it is that a
Mary Margaret and Emma
let me say sad is what I love about the
show you have to present a story for
costumes that are iconic enough to wear
yes I love it
bird on your shoulders genius though our
question is on a show like this with so
many intense scenes and frankly
character deaths um
what goes into preparing for little
scenes and getting into the right mind
frame uh for all of us oh um do you
understand see it depends on the scene
or the the day you know um I've died
what is it three or four times
you did say you're good at surviving
but so sometimes there was one where
hook sacrificed himself as the dark dark
when he gets a man to stop him whenever
I'm we know that was way harder I mean
yeah there's like a really late night
with some of those in service that can
be that can be a heart but you sort of
well we're as a cast we're all so
comfortable with each other and trust
each other so it's easy to work together
and sort of um you know kind of failure
that and get there so it's with this
cast it's great it's easy
I think everybody's different for me I
try to use stuff that's really personal
to make it feel as real as possible
because otherwise you know it doesn't
have the depth of meaning I guess you
know so I try to kind of apply things in
my life it would be really hard to lose
and find a way to kind of flush out some
of those substitutions
um I every scene is well it's different
and it requires different preparation so
some scenes you know you kind of need to
stay a little more focused in quiet and
centered and some when we have these big
like hero moments when we're all in
groups together it's really nice we have
a lot of fun and and that's part of
preparation it brings us all together
and and yes there's this story Regina
story is so complex that using her life
is is very beneficial just thinking
about what she goes through and how that
moves me and how that affects me and
and like Jen and probably a lot of other
actors we do use personal life our
personal life does health and just
finding okay
have I been through a similar experience
that's really helpful how do you relate
to this particular character of this
experience and and how would you react
now you try to remember that time
someone reached into your chest or
ritual I mean it is district for
everybody everybody has a different way
of going through like the guys have said
and you know it all goes it all starts
with the writing and script and we all
have character histories and over six
seasons these characters are so rich
with you know different levels of
emotion and different stories so you
just draw on that as much as you can
ya know the same things yeah like you're
saying well that's one of the beauties
of being this far into a series is you
do have a history that you've lived and
experienced through this character so
you as much as I draw from my personal
life as something else have said that
yeah you get to do that with your
character now because we've spent so
much time with them so that's pretty
cool one thing that really helps me like
the slides thinking about you know if
I've got to get really emotional for a
scene I think about awful things that
have happened to me and I'll sit in it
but if I you know TV we shoot really
really quickly so you might not have a
long time to really get somewhere
emotionally so if I need to expedite the
situation I'll find songs that really
make people make me cry so I love to cry
sometimes it's not a really good cry
with a glass of wine
I've got certain song about Oh
by myself
so I've got like some real dark songs
I'll just sit in my chair and get in
this horrible mood and then go out there
and take it this means so much I know
your Walker
it's my iPod that makes me like this let
the tunes in the head music is really
helpful well I agree with you when in
situations like that you try and pull
from your personal life but at this
point we're so far in the show that we
have all connections with each other and
are so close as a caste that it's easy
to work together to get to that
emotional state yeah so I like yes nice
thank you thank you thank you okay guys
so we've gotten to the point where we
have to stop taking audience questions
but what's your name um I'm Alexis
Alexis I want Collin go home with you so
could you come up here and get
please remember to feed him Roderick you
work clock yeah how are you gonna do
this now see you didn't think it through
what are you going to do now he's a star
with the right arm in danger for okay
guys so look Thank You Rebecca for doing
that wonderful vocal stylings just
because I'm about to ask the question I
asked every year and I'ma keep asking to
somebody does this for me I need a
musical episode of once upon a time
doggone it we're all like look out Hill
it should be Christmas let's do a
Christmas musical episode of what's one
time and I will even come and sing
jingle bells are what kind of doing
let's do it
everybody up here has musical talent I
want it I need it why don't you want to
say it nice things
you